and roger daltrey is with us this
morning welcome Roger good to be the mr.
kibble white you referred to in the
title was your grammar school headmaster
who said to you what well it was a it
was either the last day of my 14th year
or my 15th birthday I can't quite
remember which but he expelled me from
the school after after giving me 6
strokes of the cane for being a rather
naughty boy well as I was leaving his
office he held the door open for me and
as I walked past him eating you'll never
make anything of your life Daltrey
[Laughter]
immediately with the arrogance and you
know the anger and all that was going
through me of youth I thought I'll show
you thanks a lot mr. kibble way no but
I've had come kind of second kind of
contact with his family because I really
mean it today as a thank you because I
do wonder if he hadn't have said that to
me which way my life would have gone
because it resonated with you it's done
oh yeah I mean it was yeah it was was
the fuel kicking the butt that I needed
yeah not before a stint though is a
sheet metal worker and you after getting
kicked out of school I mean how did that
trajectory lead you to a band well I was
already in the band I was one of the
reasons I got kicked out the school is I
was already in a band and that's all I
wanted to do I mean school seemed like a
punishment the band seemed like fun yeah
so that was easy but you know in those
days it's very hard to get Americans to
kind of understand the world that we
grew up in in england post-war England
yes because everything had been leveled
it was a very bleak world I was born in
a v1 raid my mom you know she I started
she started labour on a 29th of February
so she was determined I was not going to
be elite me a baby even though I was now
been 18 years old
quite a wonderful year though so she
hung on and hung on through this era he
didn't and where the V ones were coming
down and I was born on March the 1st I'm
mum you write in the book and it was
really interesting to me to sort of see
the little pieces of the who come
together and the way that you all I
think you refer to it as like a jigsaw
puzzle and figuring it out how simple or
how difficult was it to find all the
pieces or did you just know each time
well this is the thing about being it
being the singer in a band you never
actually see much of the rest of the
group yeah you should face in front
playing to the crowd that way yeah and
they're trying to bear yeah so but what
you do because of that position is you
feel so it always became obvious when
someone had the same kind of biorhythm
and what a time Keith Moon joined it was
the last piece of the tour he was like
the key in the ignition of the engine
and all of a sudden then becomes the
algorithm yeah we're all out by our
rhythms are the same the algorithm of
the who fired up for the first time and
it was off I mean immediately you are
something big happened you you were
always a always a dynamic live band but
but you you write that actually Pete
Townsend's guitar smashing which became
early on was one of the trademarks of
the band actually started by accident
yeah accident and a temper club and it
had a very low ceiling and he used to
have this thing about planes guitar that
way across kind of that way yeah at
times I just bring it up like that you
may I think he may have jumped a little
bit and it's very low ceiling and he the
neck of the guitar just hit the ceiling
and broke mm-hmm in which that you know
made sounding completely furious a
Rickenbacker which in those days you
know the equivalent today would probably
$10,000 yeah talk to where we were in
financial straits and he proceeded to it
could have been repaired not after he'd
finished what did you think it was
smashing the guitar I have ordered what
I could what I would have done for that
guitar four years earlier when I was
making my own guitars through lack of
money yeah
but equally we saw what the effect it
had on the audience they went crazy and
we thought well this might be another
key in the door to success yeah into the
budget
it wasn't the key in the door to make it
any money
right we went up some great debts I tell
you what is so interesting about your
story is what was not part of your life
you've been with your wife where you say
50 years how did you sort of withstand
all of that that was being I'm sure
thrown at you it wasn't easy but I've
got very lucky that I'm married I met a
woman hello my wife and she understood
our business she been in the business
she been on Broadway and she was a model
and we wanted to have children and so we
want to get married and I said but you
know the business I mean he's kind of
very transient there's always temptation
it's never going to be easy and I can't
promise you I'll ever be one of those
you know
that kind of loyal husband I'm in a rock
and roll band and we were away for
months on end and I'm very young and she
accepted it and she and to accredit she
accepted it and we it was never an issue
in our marriage we we love each other we
I always loathed the term that the press
put on the girls that Pam around bands
in those days as groupies right I know
it was a nice print print name but they
were all friends they were really
wonderful people and with the ones that
are still around with still friends too
this day you write about a lot of them
about that in the book and he's running
to see some of it you also talk about
Woodstock which I think for most of us
we think yes everyone loved everyone who
was a part of it it was the greatest
thing out there and the look on your
face and everything not if you were
actually playing in it well it was it
was to say the least interesting yeah
you know it's first time I've really
come in contact with fight news because
we we would do to play the Saturday
night and we were watching the TV on the
Friday which is the first day of the
festival and if you watch the news in
when I was in Connecticut and New York I
don't know about the rest of the country
but I mean it was being declared a
disaster area apparently the governor
had closed all the roads no one was
allowed in all the bands were having to
fly in by helicopter so there was this
whole myth being kind of pumped out by
the news that was actually not true it
was we we wondering how we're gonna get
in the next day we just drove there in
the Volkswagen windsock in your in-laws
with the mother and father-in-law and
Heather and me in the back Joe and drove
to Woodstock in this little red
Volkswagen and every time we came to a
robot we just drove around it and yeah
you know it was kind of weird and then
there were no helicopters taking us in
and out we went in and out in in a
station ready man you did a lot of
waiting around you're not particularly
fond of well you know when you choose to
go on at nine o'clock at night being in
our business you type you get used to be
a bit like an athlete where you're ready
to run a race yeah oh you your whole
energy of the day is focused to be at
his height at that time of day and we
were due to go on at nine o'clock at
night we ended up going on at five
o'clock in the morning yeah needless to
say
there was not much to read on the site
there wasn't there was very little to
drink that hadn't been doctored in some
kind you got yeah that was actually
doctor well I don't know you I don't
know what it was the lab I was in a very
funny
what was the crowd like at five o'clock
in the morning I mean it was incredible
I mean and I have to say that that
everybody said you know the band bands
and the WHO and all those people with
the stars of Woodstock that's not true
the audience the people in the crowd
they were the stars of Woodstock let's
talk about the audience that you you now
play to you have still have an
incredible fandom out there I noticed
something you and I have in common
I opened the 1984 Olympics you closed
the night 2012 Olympics they aren't
necessarily who fans though who fans
what what's the difference in playing to
a crowd like that that's for me no
difference where I'm no I don't really
care who I play to I don't care if it's
one person one hundred thousand one you
know two hundred thousand two million or
whatever
I only ever sing to you you know it's no
different if there's you know five
hundred thousand of you because it's all
you
so I try not to sing at people but to
them Wow I wanna I want ask you a
question about sort of the arc of this
band because I mean you started as as
all sort of 60s rock and roll bands did
as a singles band but but with Tommy you
really became kind of an album band and
and you said you thought Tommy kind of
lifted you as a performer to a different
level
yeah and Tommy it was that came from our
manager kit Lambert who was a son of a
very famous English composer and
conductor constant Lambert and he who
always felt that the the three-minute
pop song could be be much more important
and Kip was kind of schooled in Grand
Opera and all that
yeah and he thought well it's time for a
rock opera and he guided the the music
that we were making into making into
becoming dummy he kind of wrote the book
the early book and for a singer it was a
joy it and to not have to just to do
individual songs but try and make these
individual songs into something that's
got more going on in it mm-hmm and as as
it was about a single singular character
it helped me grow as a singer from
endlessly what changed then do you think
well everything I mean the band grew
musica musically in the next three years
probably the fastest we've done their
whole career we we were freed of so many
restrictions the three-minute pop song
thing that kind of was it was big
responsibility because you're always
trying to get that hit that hit that hit
all of a sudden we were free of that
yeah and what about none of it didn't
matter anymore this is an opera yeah
what about and what about you as a
singer because it seems like you left to
another level there - yeah but I mean
again that's because I was kind of
getting into his character of going the
Tommy character I mean deaf dumb and
blind imagine in life you know through
just vibration and it's and trying to
understand and empathize with the words
you know in a way that the character
would build and it gave my voice of
strength it hadn't had previously I had
it in the blues voice I had kind of
struggled with the with these singles
when we had I'm a boy and I'm happy jack
right pictures of Lily which were kind
of rare but more more internally Pete
Townsend and I'd struggled to find that
voice but listening back to him I think
it works and because I'm kind of haunted
when one last thing before we let you go
which I have to ask you about because
you read about this in the book you and
Pete Townsend you've been together for
whatever 50 odd years and 60
and you as you describe it as like as
like a Brotherhood but there was a
moment it came to blows back I think in
the 70s and he actually swung a guitar
at you yeah he was drunk he was drunk
and yeah yeah he was drunk
and I'd been on probation I got thrown
out the group in the 60s for fighting
like staff at quite a lot and one of the
reasons I went back there's two reasons
I went back but I promise not to fight
anymore
yeah and they promise not to take drugs
before they went onstage anymore yeah so
that was the agreement and we lived up
to it for about seven years 1973 we
would rehearsing Quadrophenia and they
were a camera crew supposed to be
filming the rehearsal yeah and I was
sitting on their camera boxes I didn't
film a foot of this whole rehearsal and
so I said you know when are you gonna
start filming guys she's a hard piece of
work to sing it I'm not doing it so it's
yeah it was towards the end anyway by
this time people who they're now drunk
about at least one bottle of brandy
maybe a bottle and a half yeah Wow
started to have a gun at me you know
you're diligent told him and he started
spitting at me and with this the road
crew who know kind of do what my red
mist was like instead of kind of st.
Pete you know she's all right Pete yeah
they jump on me and hold me
it's like both arms and then with that
Pete starts quoting me and interested
will let him go I'll kill him and he
used a few expletives attached to that
yeah which weren't very complimentary
anyway they let me go he swung a guitar
at me which glanced off my shoulder then
he started throwing punches and blessing
Pete Pete was he was drunk even when
he's sober he's not a fighter
he threw a punch which what kind of went
past my left ear again and he Bentley
presenting his he's from in and face to
me and I just hit him and he kind of
left the floor and went bang I need I
thought I killed him holding his hand
patent his head keep crying because I
feel I killed him sound like your
childhood story that it was the reverse
roll myself and our manager and Pete on
a stretcher we're holding Pete's hand in
the ambulance guilty about that I I wish
I hadn't have hit him but it was I get
there's no choice you know if that
guitar hit me it might have killed me
mm-hm
are the who done or you know no no no no
no no no no it will be done when we
can't do it
we can't do it as it needs to be done
anymore and they're still they're still
avenues to explore we've got ideas for
maybe something next year you can't
obviously go home for long but there's
something about the who I'm really proud
of there's a there's a energy in the who
that we've never cheated and if that's
the thing if I ever feel isn't there in
me anymore because it can only I can't
speak for Pete but if it isn't in me as
the singer to deliver those songs and
give them that energy that is true rock
not rock and roll rock and roll's music
to make love to the music of the who is
music to fight to Roger Daltrey the book
is thanks a lot mr. kibble wait good
luck with it and thank you so much for
being with us thanks for having me